The Walking Dead is one of the most popular
shows on television, yet some of its stars
are still mostly unknown.
For instance, consider Lauren Cohan.
She's played Maggie for five seasons, but
how much do you really know about her?
Here are some fun things that most fans of
The Walking Dead probably don't know about
the career of one of the show's toughest survivors.
She grew up in the UK
If you've heard Lauren Cohan speak out of
character, it's probably a bit jarring to
discover she has an English accent.
So what gives?
Turns out that Cohan's mother is English.
Mystery solved!
“I was born in New Jersey, my mom is English
my dad is American and I move to England so
I have a bit of a, a bit of a the both sides
of the pond…”
Supernatural Star
Cohan got her big break in 2005 with a role
in the film Casanova, then followed it up
the next year with a role in Van Wilder: The
Rise of Taj.
But it was her turn as Bela Talbot on Supernatural
that first brought her to the widespread attention
of television fans.
Unfortunately, that attention was...less than
positive.
An anti-hero who stole magical artifacts and
sold them to the highest bidder, Bela proved
to be wildly unpopular with fans.
After just six episodes, she was killed off.
It just proves that fans are even deadlier
than zombies.
Moment of Immortality
It's no surprise that the producers of The
Walking Dead approached Lauren for the role
of Maggie given that she already had a reputation
in the industry for playing strong women on
horror shows.
Case in point: after ending her run on Supernatural,
Cohan landed a recurring role on The Vampire
Diaries as Rose, an immortal vampire.
Sadly, immortality isn't quite what it used
to be, and after six episodes she was staked
through the heart.
“One, Two”
Alas!
Bad Luck for Chuck
In 2011, Cohan took a break from the world
of television horror and instead became a
villainous superspy on Chuck.
In the role of Vivian McArthur Volkoff, Cohan
went full-on evil, hiring hitmen to assassinate
Zachary Levi's lead character and even attempting
to murder his fiancée out of revenge.
“Ok you don’t do things like this.
Please don’t do this.”
“I already have.”
That doesn't sound like sweet Maggie at all!
Commitment Issues
Fun fact: Cohan almost missed out on The Walking
Dead because she was under contract to a different
show.
Back in 2011, Cohan filmed a pilot for The
CW called Heavenly, in which she played a
lawyer who teamed up with an angel to… fight
crime or something?
Fellow CW stars Ben Aldridge and Ryan Eggold
were also cast, but despite the network nepotism,
The CW passed on Heavenly, freeing her up
to do The Walking Dead instead.
“Yeah, Woooo, Yeah, Wooo, Yeah”
Horror Hater
Perhaps the craziest thing about Cohan's career?
Even though all of her most famous roles have
come in horror stories, including her part
in the feature film The Boy, she isn't actually
much of a fan of the genre.
In fact, she told Media Blvd.
Magazine that it scares her to death:
"I have a very weak stomach for horror.
It's great, but it's something that you want
to watch with a girlfriend or a friend because
you can scream with somebody else."
You don't have to tell that to Walking Dead
fans.
They already know.
“Neighbors heard screaming and gunshots
coming from a family's home so officers raced
to the scene and Mass, turns out the family
was watching The Walking Dead”
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
of Lauren's TV roles is your favorite…